hallo mein Name ist Luca meine lieben
Freunde ihr wisst das heute Dienstag ist
und was kommt am Dienstag richtig das
beschissenste Format in ganz Youtube
Deutschland namens tiktok Tuesday bevor
ich euch allerdings gleich meine Top
tiktoks der Woche zeige möchte euch nur
ganz kurz sagen dass ich eben auch ein
neues Video auf tiktok hochgeladen habe
und zwar ist das ein richball Check in
dem ich euch unter anderem meine neue
Rolex zeige euch meinen neuen Gucci
Pullover präsentiere und euch auch meine
neuen Airport zeige also wenn ihr das
noch nicht gesehen habt folgt mir gerne
auf tiktok ich heiße Laser Luca und
schaut euch da gerne an aber jetzt
fangen wir an mit dem ersten Video
dieser heutigen Folge tiktok Tuesday
[Musik]
kann man Wasser anders auch
nein es geht nicht
[Musik]
ich schwöre ich hatte noch nie einen
richtigen Krampf so wirklich ey ich
wollte Alter das kann doch nicht
beschreiben mach das bitte nicht zu
Hause nach das ist sehr unangenehm
[Musik]
[Applaus]
alles klar
super Content bisher hier zu Beginn ich
habe einen Krampf und ein Typ Furz mir
ins Ohr
ganz ehrlich ich schwöre ich sag's in
jeder Folge tiktok User aber das
die Wahrheit genau so wie man in
Deutschland umfahren als Wort benutzt
weil man etwas umfährt aber auch als
Wort benutzt wenn man etwas umfährt
das ist einfach aua das war mein Finger
macht einfach vorne und hinten keinen
Sinn aber ja wir machen weiter mit einer
nächsten Sache die auch vorne und hinten
keinen Sinn macht
die Wahrheit sag mal man kennt ihn
Freunde
ja das könnte auch so ein tiktok von mir
sein schreibt mir bei Amazon eine neue
Decke bestellt und es ist so ein geiles
Material hält so warm ist echt absolute
Hammer
ja
lassen wir mal so stehen
[Musik]
hat weh getan in der Tat bin ich schon
länger in meinen Videos nicht mehr
erwähnt habe ist alpakalino wie geht's
dir da hinten eigentlich immer nur von
hinten sehe geht's mir eigentlich ganz
gut aber wenn du dich umdrehst kotze ich
beim Anblick deiner Visage immer in mein
Fell Amina Koi alles klar danke für die
netten Worte
dann kommst du und machst es zu
[Musik]
ich liebe solche Videos die Pornos
reasonsive
[Musik]
aber es ist auch wieder die Wahrheit das
habe ich eine letzte Folge schon gesagt
Leute werden auf tiktok bekannt mit dem
bescheuerten Sachen ich habe letztens
einfach es ging ein Stoppschild gerannt
30 Millionen Aufrufe quality content so
könnt ihr mit Fake airpods flexen sehen
aber echt aus macht so ein Stil so ein
knöd und klebt die mit washi tape klebt
den Stiel an den Knödel so dann sind sie
fertig
cool oder schreibt in die Kommentare
wenn ihr sie verlosen soll
weiß ich ob sie das ernst weil das ganze
Video wenn sie es ernst weil dann ist es
extrem süß aber wenn sie es nicht ernst
meint dann ist es einfach wirklich
extrem lustig so ich meine die sind halt
über mich aus wie Airport
hey guten Morgen
[Musik]
es ist halt realtalk immer so gewesen
wenn man bei Freunden gepennt hat so die
haben irgendwie schon im Bett gepennt
man setzt sich auf dem Boden auf der
Isomatte oder so richtig beschissen auf
die Nase
auf die Nase und auf dem Kopf
ist wieder so ein Paradebeispiel von
Personen die absolut überhaupt keinen
Schaden Gefühl haben sagt mal i like
Cops aber ohne dass sie Lippen sich
berühren i like echt
[Musik]
wir machen weiter mit dem nächsten Video
auf so eine Scheiße muss halt erstmal
kommen auf diesem Schild steht dass ich
in diesem See ein Hecht befindet wenn
wir aber genau hinsehen merken wir wir
sehen gar keinen Hecht
das liegt daran dass er sich unter dem
Eis befindet wow was
[Musik]
ey was krass das ja was WoW
und dadurch
es ist die Wahrheit es ist einfach wahr
jedes Mal wenn man so ein Akkuschrauber
in die Hand nimmt und dann das so erhält
dann man macht immer
[Musik]
ist einfach die Wahrheit und jeder der
ist verleugnet der ist eine blöde
Softbox gesichtsgrätsche okay
what time meiner Sex
[Musik]
das ist für mich das tiktok der Woche
also lieber User mit dem
namen@evc nobel du hast für mich hier
das tiktok der Woche gewonnen lass ihm
alle mal einen schönen Gruß da und
kommentiert unter diesem Video deinen
Apfel weil dann Apple day keeps the
doctor in the way
[Musik]
hält auch gar nicht den Doktor weg
[Applaus]
[Musik]
kann ich das auch
meine Nase gebrochen
[Musik]
so was in der heutigen Folge haben wir
zwei tiktoks der Woche also auch der
User mit dem Namen Cameron
mc372 du hast auch gewonnen
[Musik]
ich freue mich schon so darauf wenn ich
selber bald endlich einen Hund habe ne
ich werde noch die ganze Zeit so ein
schwarze mit dir machen ich freue mich
so mega
[Musik]
ja es gibt halt solche Leute auf tiktok
ne die so krank Trickshots machen und
dann gibt's mich der letztens mit einem
Dartpfeil in seinem Mülleimer werfen
wollte und das ganze schlussendlich ja
sieht einfach selbst Kobe
ich bin
schon fettes Opfer willkommen bei
McDonald's
dann dann wenn wir dann da sind dass wir
dann sprachen lernen babbelstation
Südamerika wo kommst ab und zu wirklich
krass ausrasten bei irgendwelchen Leuten
die irgendwie Schwachsinn machen oder
sich einen Spaß erlauben oder so muss
man sich erstmal trauen an der uno-karte
zu zeigen also Respekt zu dir auf jeden
Fall gegenüber hallo Ist jemand deutsch
nein bist du nicht deutsch
und was bist du sonst
das ist hundertprozentig die Wahrheit
Alter das bin ich wie ich überlege zu
Meckes zu gehen das bin ich wie ich mich
fertig mache um zu Meckes zu gehen ich
im Auto alleine auf dem Weg zur Meckes
das bin ich wie ich mein Essen bei
Mecces bestell das bin ich wie ich warte
das bin ich wie ich alleine bei Mecces
mein Essen esse das bin ich wie ich noch
ein McFlurry bestell das bin ich und der
McFlurry das bin ich alleine im Auto auf
dem Weg nach Hause das bin ich nach
Mecces Essen das bin ich wie ich gerade
die zehn Euro die ich ausgegeben habe
bereue
sag mal was mache ich eigentlich hier
mit meinem Leben
ist mein absolutes beschissenes Format
was wenn euch die heutige Folge tiktok
User gefallen hat dann zeig's mir gerne
mit einem Daumen hoch unter dem Video
hier schaffen wir 50 000 likes das wäre
mega krass und wird mir zeigen dass euch
diese Serie gefällt falls ihr noch kein
Teil der duschseite dann abonniert gern
meinen Kanal folgt mir gerne auf tiktok
ich heiße der Laser Luca ich habe dort
auch heute ein neues tik tok Video
hochgeladen und jetzt kommt das outroom
[Musik]